Rod's
would hey what's up guys and welcome to
my tutorial for thee the ninja na in my
last video I asked you whether you
wanted to see the ninja knot or the
paper popper and although the votes came
pretty close more people wanted to see
the ninja not so that's what I'm going
to show you how to today if I do have
some time this weekend I will teach how
to make the paper popper the ninja knot
is officially called Ian's not because
it was meant by Ian fegan and was
officially released to the internet back
in 2000 I learned it from his website
which you can check out by clicking the
link down in the video description below
it's the world's fastest shoelace knot
and it's not only great for tying
shoelaces but you saw you can also tie
other things as well so once you're
ready to go grab your shoes and we'll
get started
that way we can avoid things like this
oh yeah what is it the end of the world
oh oh I'm late
whoa come on man No
let me take this test what was it bunny
ears left right what did mom show me
okay
to make things easier for you to see in
the tutorial I put a white lace in the
shoe as well as the blue one that I
already had now for the ninja knot just
like for any other knot that you would
use for your shoe we need to have what's
called a starting knot the starting knot
for the ninja knot requires that you
take the left lace you put it over the
right lace and then you pull the left
lace underneath it just like that that's
called the starting knot if you were to
take the right lace put it on top of the
left lace and then tuck the right one
underneath the ninja knot would still
come out except it would come out
crooked and it would come undone a
little bit easier that's called the
granny knot and it's just because of the
way that the lace is line up so for the
purposes of the ninja knot we're going
to take the left lace put it on top of
the right lace and we're going to tuck
the left one underneath and pull now
that we have our starting knot we can
get to doing the ninja knot for the
ninja not what we're going to do is
we're going to take both of our hands
and you're going to use the last three
fingers to grab onto both laces like
this okay so hold on to both laces and
you want to leave a little bit of space
between your hands and the shoe maybe if
you extend your thumbs it should be
about that length all right
now you want to have your pointer and
thumbs free holding both of the strings
like this you're going to take the
pointer and thumb of your right hand
tuck it underneath from the front like
this and face it away from you you're
going to take the pointer and thumb of
your left hand and you're going to tuck
it underneath from the back from this
way and you're going to point it towards
you okay now this is important so it
needs to be that way now what we're
going to do is we're going to
twist both of our hands so that we join
and meet up our pointers and thumbs now
what we're going to do with our right
hand is we're going to take our pointer
and thumb and we're going to grab onto
this white lace the lace in between my
left pointer and left thumb this portion
right here is where I'm going to grab
okay now what I'm going to do with my
left hand is I'm going to take my
pointer and I'm going to push down right
on top of my right pointer finger right
where this blue lace is lying and I'm
going to take that blue lace and I'm
going to pull it through underneath the
white lace once I pull it through I'm
going to take my left thumb and I'm
going to pinch it then what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to pull both ends
and as you'll see that's the ninja not
all right so you guys know me I like to
go through things in super detail
because you know I'm not there to see
whether or not you understand so I have
to make sure that this video explains
everything in a clear manner so that
everyone can understand it and you know
they should be able to get it from this
video to untie the knot we just pull on
the loose ends like that just like you
would for a regular knot and here is our
starting knot so you can just untie that
as well so from the beginning again the
left lace goes on top of the right lace
like that and the left lace gets tucked
underneath the right lace and pulled
through then you can tighten it and
that's our starting knot once again we
grab both laces with our last three
fingers make sure it's a pretty snug or
tight pull okay
free pointers and thumbs on the right
side it goes underneath and faces away
from us like that left side underneath
and faces towards us okay
shift things so that we join our
pointers and thumbs
grab the portion on my left hand in
between my pointer and thumb with my
right pointer and thumb just like this
now my left pointer is going to grab the
portion of lace that's lying on top of
my right pointer so you can basically
let go with the last three fingers on
the right hand and you're going to pull
that portion underneath that white lace
there and you're just going to pull
those two loops apart and there you go
you should have it now if you were to
grab both ends and let's say you go
under like this you go from you've both
hands are facing away from you well you
could still line it up but when you go
to do the ninja knot you'll see you'll
get something like this and you'll be
like what's going on
well that's because you can't join it
like that you need to make sure that the
hands are in opposite directions
grab the laces right hands facing away
left hand is facing towards you okay
bring them together grab this portion
and grab that portion and pull so when
you get pretty quick at it you'll see
it's it's a pretty efficient knot and I
don't tie my shoes any other way besides
this way because there's no reason to it
it's a very snug knot and it's tight and
it won't come undone especially if you
make sure that you're doing the proper
starting knot
so again got them both underneath and
grab there you go
so hopefully you guys understood it from
that video if you have any questions or
feedback please leave it in the comments
section below and have fun breaking
World Records with the new shoe tying
method that you learned I call it the
ninja knot but as you're well aware it
is invented by Ian feegan and is also
known as Ian's not so thank you very
much Ian fegan for creating such an
awesome knot I hope you guys enjoyed the
video please rate comment and subscribe
for further notification